[Music]
hi and welcome to how to make better
products with Android things I'm Kristen
and I'm UX lead for Android things my
name is Michael I'm the UX design
manager for Android things you can think
about this talk as product design 101
for people who may not be designers but
if you are a designer we got you covered
we'll be covering hardware prototyping
and the possibilities of what you can
create using Android things in this talk
we'll cover how you can accelerate the
prototyping and product creation process
using Android things we'll talk about a
design framework that you can use
starting today to help you think about
who your users are and how they can play
a more prominent role in crafting the
products that you're creating and we'll
also talk about a concept project called
Lantern to demonstrate how we've applied
the design framework to use Android
rings to create better products thanks
Michael so we know that hardware design
is a long and difficult process it can
take anywhere from two to five years to
bring a product from ideation all the
way up to product so you start with
ideation and then you move on to the
prototype phase and then you choose your
hardware and then you design your
software and get that all coated up and
then you send it to a factory you
finally get done on the store shelf and
then you cycle back and you have to go
through updates so we live in a world
that's rapidly changing and technology
can change right in the middle of your
production process so how can the design
process keep up that's one of the main
reasons that we created Android things
it's made for a world that's rapidly
changing and enables people to be part
of the creation process from ideation
all the way through maintenance so at
the heart of Android things there's
something called a sum or a system on
module ok and this is also called a
carrier board the song can be used for
prototyping and it can be also placed on
a custom board so you can snap this song
off and use it on your own custom PCB
board ok and this carrier board
everything that surrounds this carrier
board is an accessory so everything from
the Ethernet to power to the headphone
jack over here this is a powerful tool
for prototyping because you already have
a lot of tools that you need to get
connected and of course if you need a
different peripheral you can easily
connect it using traditional methods
like pins of breadboard and resistors so
Android Things offers a number of tools
for you to get started easily there is
the kit which has an imx7 developer
board a touchscreen and a stand so for
those of you who have gotten your kit
already or maybe been to some of the
code labs the kit assembles into a
useful stand that you can use to
prototype right on your desk in addition
to the kit we offer the Android things
toolkit app to help you get on to Wi-Fi
really easily one of the pain points
that we heard from developers in the
code labs droidcon for example was
provisioning the devices on to the Wi-Fi
network was difficult so with the
toolkit app you can get it on to Wi-Fi
but in a breeze it'll also step you
through the process of making sure that
your hardware is connected correctly and
with recent updates to the toolkit app
we also have some samples that you can
load from the app onto your device to
see some of the powerful things that
Android things can do like running the
tensorflow demonstrations before you get
into Android studio in addition to the
toolkit app and the hardware kit we also
recently updated the Android things dot
with Google comm community hub so now we
offer code snippets samples drivers and
projects from the community so if you do
build something cool you can submit it
and we'll feature it on the site we also
recently updated the site to include
driver submission so that if you do
write a cool driver and you do want to
submit it for other people to use we can
have that on the site as well if you
haven't already gotten your kit head
over to the i/o dome and they'll give
you information about how to get one
thanks
so Android things provides an end-to-end
solution it offers tools from prototype
to production
Michael mentioned the psalm makes
hardware selection easier by offering
modular hardware solutions so you can
use the same TAS on for prototyping as
you do production for prototyping the
kit offers peripherals such as displays
a camera a rainbow hat for sensor input
and interface output and also an antenna
to connect the device to Wi-Fi an app
also makes this easier as Michael
mentioned to assemble your hardware and
it also helps you get familiar with your
carrier board and it helps you connect
to Wi-Fi and finally when you're ready
for production the developer console can
help you create builds configure your
firmware and release those builds to
devices
great
so we wanted to share with you a concept
called Lantern and we're using this as a
demonstration to help you understand how
we were able to use Android things to
bring products to life so Lantern is not
a Google product but it's a project that
we worked on with the Nord group that
creates augmented reality anywhere
around you and so you can see this as an
easy an easy to understand example of
how we were exploring creativity through
prototyping and again we wanted to show
you the possibilities of what you can
create what we can create or the
possibilities of what can be created
with Android things so at its heart
Lantern is obviously a lamp but it's a
lamp that enables you to create
augmented reality anywhere around you
and it's you it's created using
off-the-shelf parts and we thought that
was really important because we wanted
to make sure that as a recipe that you
could potentially build one on your own
so what is augmented reality you may
have heard this term AR there's the AR
kit but how can we create this sense of
augmented reality using Android things
so using Lantern and Android rings we
wanted to project onto everyday objects
interesting pieces of information and
content that may be trapped inside the
phone or on the web but that may enhance
the world around us so say for example
here
the currently playing calf song we're
projecting it on to a speaker and none
of this was done using After Effects
this is all using the projection system
in the prototype that we created another
example of how we Rock menteng everyday
objects is in this example a clock so
we're using Google Calendar and a wall
clock with Lantern to project the
calendar information around the clock
and again this is all real we shot this
in the studio using the projected land
using Lantern on as an exploration here
we felt like it looked particularly good
because it was on this nice curved round
surface so it gave this ticker ticker
tape kind of look but we're excited
about these possibilities and that's why
we wanted to create this to share with
you to demonstrate not only our design
process which we'll get into but also to
give it to the community to see what you
guys may want to create with it and so
what is Lantern made of I mentioned
before that it was created using
off-the-shelf parts so there's a lamp
inside is a laser projector an
accelerometer a 3d printed housing and
Raspberry Pi running Android things it's
important to recognize that there are
two pieces of hardware that Android
things - boards excuse me that Android
things runs on it'll run on a Raspberry
Pi and it also run on the imx7 boards
that are in that are in the kit the
Raspberry Pi is is a little bit more
prevalent at this point in the maker
community so we felt like building it on
that platform with the HDMI output was
going to be better for this case because
we could connect it directly to the
laser projector and so once it's
assembled it looks like this you may
have seen it over in the IOT dome we
have one running over there as an
example and we really believe that this
is only now possible because of the
democratization of design and hardware
and prototyping and access to these
kinds of tools that we're talking about
today so it was really difficult in the
past to say print a 3d form like this
and assemble it into a hardware shell
because hardware was expensive 3d
prototyping tools were inaccessible and
tools like Android things were not easy
really readily available for you to
access to create new hardware prototypes
and so Lantern can also be assigned
content to its its particular context so
it's aware of its orientation
so using that accelerometer in Lantern
we can change its base position and then
project different content onto different
surfaces so say we wanted to project a
star chart on the ceiling or in the
examples that we saw earlier you could
see the calendar information projected
onto the wall this code is available
today at github comm slash nord project
sash lantern if you want to check it out
download the source code and build your
own so we didn't set out to create
Lantern so where did Lantern come from
you can see a number of sketches that we
created and if your designers you may be
familiar with AI da ting through
sketching but we have an inclination
that projected systems would be
interesting when we started prototyping
using Android things but we use design
to turn idea into a real thing and today
we want to share with you the process
that we went through and the frameworks
that we used to create amazing products
so you can - thank you
so as Michael mentioned design helps
create better better products how many
of you with a raise of hand have created
something that was used by another
person go ahead and raise your hands oh
that's awesome so when we design things
you might know that we use common
principles to ground our work a lot of
the things that we design can be carried
over from software into hardware from a
banking app for instance to a theater
app there's another instance so we use
these processes and forend principles to
ground our work but then we use the
design process to move forward as well
and then we continue iterating with
Android things we're taking some of the
software UI design concepts and applying
them to hardware
so what is design design is the creation
of tools for people in a context to help
them achieve a goal if any of you are
familiar with the development process
this is very similar to a user story so
for example as a dog owner I want to I
want to connect a dog feeder so that I
can feed my dog from work or as a person
who orders pizza I ordered pizza all the
time
I want visibility into the delivery
route so I know when my pizza will
arrive or something like a simple story
as a night I want a stronger sword so
that I can defeat the dragon now taking
the knight example we framed out that
the knight wants a stronger sword this
is a tool that the knight uses to
achieve his goal of defeating the dragon
we call this tool an interface so people
people typically think of a user
interface is a touchscreen or a mobile
phone or a tablet because you can tap on
the screen and things happen right it's
magic and while this is true user
interface is much broader than that like
in the example I used before the user
interface is the sword but we can see
here from this slide that a button can
be used to build upon an interface to
create a joystick which can be used to
create a game that shoots down aliens
from the sky and then there could be
feedback on top of that where there's
leds inside of a breadboard that light
up when you push the button right so all
of these are is an example of a user
interface but one of the most simple
user interfaces that we use to design
things as simple as a piece of paper and
a pen and admittedly a design is
iterative and sometimes it feels like
this right like the hamster in the wheel
that's okay the truth is is that you're
never done teams need to collectively
learn through the experience of
observation and iteration that being
said Android things enables you to
iterate faster by allowing you to work
through many design issues by using the
design kit as a base for your prototype
phase and allowing for early
over-the-air updates using the developer
console
so design is a process that can be used
to create better products for everyone
and we know that design is agnostic of
medium time trend or technology company
and we believe it's important to think
about design as a process that's
agnostic of these things so no matter
what changes you have the right tools to
apply that process when whatever problem
you're working on so we talked about
design being in the context of people
are people in the context of goals but
how is it done and what does it look
like
so each milestone outlined here planning
prototyping getting feedback in
iteration needs to be vetted right and
using this iterative framework we can
enable this to help us make less
mistakes produce better products and
have a cheaper production process along
the way because we learn earlier how the
product needs to take shape as its
evolving this will truly help you make
decisions sooner so thinking about
planning planning takes the shape of
many forms first we aim to create
baseline understandings of needs that
may exist for our users so we may begin
by talking to people about pain points
or getting inspiration from places from
pain points that we have ourselves we
may look at competitive products to
think about how they are solving
specific problems and how we may want to
do things differently if you're familiar
with design for software systems you may
be familiar with creating user personas
to get an idea of how you can gain
empathy into the mind of somebody who's
actually using your product we also
create things like wireframes
storyboards to begin to tell the story
of how we seeing the products use
unfolding over time we then create
something right so based on what we know
and the hypothesis of how something
should work we begin by creating medium
fidelity designs so we solved this
really preliminary sketches right we may
create something like a video simulation
to think about how it might look and
feel before it actually works we might
make something on a breadboard
to get an idea of what it functionally
might do
or what some of the key characteristics
of that functionality might be like and
then finally getting feedback so it's
important to get feedback in this cycle
because we need to understand how people
are actually using things so qualitative
feedback understanding the users
perception of how they feel about a
particular feature or what you're
proposing quantitative research we can
be used to gain data to understand how
specific features are you are being used
or not used internal feedback we're
constantly sharing projects with each
other internally to get feedback from
other people it's really helpful to get
an objective eye on something so that
they can so that that person can point
out something that you may not have seen
and gorilla research I'm showing your
prototype to somebody who may not be
familiar with the project can give you
tremendous insight because then you can
have an objective set of eyes on
features that you may be creating from
somebody who may not be familiar with
the project's perform and finally in
later stages you may employ something
like a lab study more formally to ask
participants to use your prototype to
see in a controlled environment side by
side what different variations may be
like and we're not saying that you need
to do all of these things along the way
so for example we may create a rough
storyboard which can then translate to a
click-through and then gain internal
feedback and iterate on that cycle or
for example we may do a bit of
competitive analysis or define some
must-have requirements and then create a
looks like feels like prototype and then
perform some gorilla research with
somebody who's not familiar with the
product we're creating
so something else to mention is that
hardware isn't hard it's just different
you need to consider what parts that you
need to make what you want you also need
to think about designing a system
possibly with non customized parts
sometimes it's like Jenga one
requirement can actually affect another
and you also need to think about future
proofing how much space do you need to
allocate for user data for example if
you're designing a camera this might be
important for users and finally you also
need to think about form factor how will
how will all of the parts that you want
to fit into your design fit into a form
factor that's delightful for your users
one other thing to consider is your
interaction design so when you click
when you connect the product to the
internet do you make a companion app for
that how do you make sure that the
notifications can be seen from a
reasonable view how do you make it
accessible take something as easy as a
software update do you tell the user at
8:00 a.m. when people are actually using
your product or do you wait until 2:00
a.m. when people might not be using your
product and they might be asleep also
what if there's no screen something else
to consider for the land of IOT so we
can apply our design process using
Android things to help us iterate faster
and get back feet get that feedback
sooner make better informed decisions
for these questions and also ultimately
help us design better products and one
thing to note if you're a software
designer something that you're really
familiar with is the undo button in
Hardware you don't have an undo button
it's really difficult to rollback or
release
sorry it's really easy to roll back and
release when you're a software engineer
as well but when you're designing for
hardware it's a lot more permanent so
you need to have a strong iteration
cycle because each time that you move
forward in your design cycle the more
expensive it gets to move backwards for
example in 1966 NASA's budget was over
four percent of u.s. spending and the
undertaking was mammoth
now for example we can shoot 3d printers
into space a simple technology up there
update it from your laptop and reuse the
Rockets all at a fraction of the price
we can shoot cars into space simply
because it's fun and because we can one
other thing to note here is the design
process so with the Mercury Gemini and
Apollo missions they were all built to
get us to the moon mercury put a man
into space Gemini to extend this to
extend the capsule stay from hours into
days and the Apollo to get us to the
moon these were some pretty big
iteration cycles but you know they were
really onto something you may also
notice that even today some hardware
design is actually based on a waterfall
process it requires everything to be
perfect and is expensive and end in
cycles so for example you start with
your requirements you hand those off
once those are done to the designers who
finish the designs and then they hand
that off in to the engineers for
implementation
once the implementation is finished off
then they hand it off to the QA
engineers for verification and then you
cycle back through a maintenance cycle
and you do that over and over again and
if you make a mistake or you decide that
you want to change if you're late in the
process you have to go all the way back
up to the requirements section so on the
right you'll see something that looks a
little bit more like the process that
Michael was talking about only except we
have a few more milestones sprinkled in
there so each one of these is an
iteration cycle you plan prototype
feedback and iterate and you keep
continuing to do that throughout your
process iteration is flexible and it
helps keep cost contained and the users
included in the process in the past
there were also very specific roles that
contribute to the creation of a project
including fabrication engineers now with
the access to tools like on-demand 3d
printing product creation has become
more democratized as Michael mentioned
before anyone can print 3d parts
designers can code visualizations now
with the ease of prototyping tools app
developers can also apply their skills
to hardware and Android things makes
that easy to do
so specifically we're dealing with
software in the past it was also
labor-intensive to create and release a
build and it was difficult to set up
testing environments for those devices
as well with Android things we've
introduced the developer console so that
users can update their app in Android
studio open up the dev console and
create and Bill create a build and
release it all in a few easy steps so
now that we've talked a little bit about
design and process we want to bring this
back to the Lantern project that I
mentioned earlier so how are we able to
use the process of planning prototyping
getting feedback and iterating to help
us improve this concept we were able to
think about people context and goals and
then apply this to the simple idea so as
a designer sitting at my desk I'd like
to bring my room to life through
projections simple idea that connects
people context and goals we started by
sketching but what happened next we
began to create a looks like feels like
prototype so before we were even
assembling Hardware or putting together
the housing we started to think about
what would a time rendering look like as
a projection if it was sitting next to
moon or what would I want to project
onto the desk in front of me as I was
typing would it be some Bitcoin
information or a price of something else
or how I'm doing in a certain game it
looks like feels like prototype can help
you understand how something how
something exists in its end state
without actually having to get there
through the full creation process so
again we went back to sketching to think
about how the housing may come together
if we're thinking about a lamp and
thinking about the parts that needed to
go in it well we as I mentioned earlier
we'd need the Raspberry Pi board we need
some sort of projector and I'd have to
start to fit inside of this specific
shape this was one of the first
prototypes that we created using foam
core in some of the parts so once we
knew the parts that we needed we began
to put them together and assemble them
not into a 3d print right away
but just using foam creating slices
cutting them out and making the form so
that we knew that they would fit into
the lamb and before we put everything
together we started to prototype what
some of these content simulations may
look like functionally so on the Left
what you're seeing is an accelerometer
tests showing how we could change
content based on orientation and again
it's really simple
we had the projector we had the
Raspberry Pi connected to an
accelerometer running Android things and
we just said can we show you the
direction or show us the direction of
which way the object is pointing
so does it know if it's pointing up down
or sideways and then on the right hand
side these were some of the initial
tests that we did looking at how we
could get the currently playing song off
of the Wi-Fi when you're casting to a
nearby device and just projecting it
onto a notepad to see is that even
possible using the hardware that we
think we want to use looking at physical
prototyping here's Joe with the first
assembled prototype looking at the
accelerometer changing the content based
on the orientation of the physical
prototype and here flips up at the
ceiling then you can see the content
start to come to life
so again we built these pieces up
individually and then started to put
them together into their final form so
one tool that I wanted to mention that
the team found highly beneficial in
creating this project was processing and
so if you're a designer you may already
be familiar with processing as a
lightweight IDE that enables you to
quickly create visualizations for
designers like me it helps me because I
can create visualizations independently
and there's a really nice library that
was really recently released from the
processing foundation called processing
for Android and what that enables you to
do is write processing and then test
that in on an Android device you can
test that on your phone you can test it
on your wear device but you can also use
that on Android things which is really
nice because you can work on a
visualization and then
that onto your Hardware independently
what this enabled us to do was work with
the visualizations get them to a place
where we wanted them and then integrate
them into the hardware I'm a few gotchas
when you're moving from processing you
can export an Android studio project
however you'll need to upgrade the
minimum SDK version in the Gradle file
in order for you to work with Android
things
so Android things requires a slightly
higher Android build number and once you
do that you'll be able to connect your
processing visualizations to hardware to
manipulate them through the standard
Android things GPIO inputs and so
thinking about our iterative process how
did we go about getting feedback on
Lantern so first we started asking team
members around us to use it we couldn't
really go out to the public because this
was a private thing that we were working
on but we were able to find other people
inside of Google who are not familiar
with the project team members such as
the ml team on Android things who
thought it was pretty interesting but
one thing that we had really kind of
pushed away from was the idea of
integrating in your interactivity into
our MVP or our first iteration of the
project
we were specifically adverse to
incorporating interactivity because we
wanted to prove that we could project
content in different ways interactivity
adds another layer of complexity so
again we wanted to simplify this into
its basic form so that we could prove
that the independent on interactions
were working however when we shared the
prototype with the ml team they were
really keen on integrating a camera and
so because we were working with Android
things and working with 3d printing we
were able to make some modifications
integrate the camera and the Norden team
happened to be working in London and the
Mountain View team was over here and it
was really an interesting story of how
this evolved because again never before
have you had access to tools like this
like 3d printing from the web we were
able to actually build prototypes into
physical locations
collaborate on them and build them up
simultaneously which is really cool and
again Android things made it really easy
to integrate new hardware like this and
connect it to the visualization pieces
in a snap and so with the camera in
place we now had the possibility of a
greater range of interactivity and
interactive input and so this led us to
creating quick-draw
pen and paper addition so for those of
you who are at i/o last year you may
have seen quick-draw which is a creative
labs project from Google that prompts
you with a word and then as you draw it
on a tablet on the web or on your phone
it starts to guess what you're drawing
and we thought that would be really cool
to do in the physical world now that we
had this projected AR system and so what
we did is we did just that
right so previously it was limited to
screen based inputs but we thought
wouldn't it be cool if we could use just
a pen paper capture that input feed that
into the quick-draw engine and then have
an interactive game that you could use
in the physical world this is an example
of the demonstration that we have set up
over in the IOT dome if you have the
visited the dome you can check it out
and you can try it out for yourselves
we've got a lantern set up and it works
it works great so you're prompted with a
word and as you start to draw with the
pen and the paper it starts to guess on
this projected interface in front of you
so again thinking about this as a mixed
reality surface and there you go
so now we've gone one through one cycle
right we've planned we've prototype in
and we've got feedback and we've
iterated on that cycle we made some
improvements and so we're done right
we're ready to ship the project no no no
we're not going to ship our product yet
so what we're going to do is start the
production process and so what this
means is we're going to move forward
maybe mass producing something like
Lantern
so Android things has many prototyping
tools to get you started after you've
completed your proof of concept and the
initial prototypes everything is working
and you know what you want it to look
like and you know you want to move over
to a custom board this is easy because
of the somme like I mentioned before you
shouldn't have to redo all of the work
that you did in the prototyping phase
just because you're using the same
architecture to create your products so
now let's say that I want to
mass-produce lantern right and it's part
of the feedback process I wanted to
learn more about factory production and
bring up processes so I visit a few
factories in China as it turns out they
have a process too and it Maps well to
the overall product design process when
you mass-produce a product the factory
will build out a line with stations each
station is staffed with people who put
together the product if I want millions
of products or millions of lanterns the
factory might automate that process and
make some really cool robots and
automate things with conveyor belts and
those robots during the whole process
though it's good for you as a product
designer to continue iterating on your
product but probably leaning more
towards software instead of hardware
changes and I'll show you why so you've
created 10 units perhaps in your
prototyping phase right and then you
send those off to the factory and there
they're going to run everything through
something called a validation test and
you start out with engineering
validation tests so you send your
prototypes to the factory and they'll
say
back maybe a hundred units and during
that time you need to make sure that
everything works with the materials that
you've selected they're probably going
to be using soft tools possibly hard
tools in this stage to create all of the
forms for your your industrial design
and then after that after you've
verified everything then you send any
feedback back to the factory and you
move on to design validation test this
is where you move on to stainless
tooling all of the stations are set up
and they're staffed with people and at
this point the product design team
should be using Android things console
to update software and update all of the
testing channels to help make your
iteration cycles go better in the mean
time you should also be doing user
testing throughout all of these phases
then when you have feedback for the
factory and you send things back then
you move on into the product validation
test this phase makes sure that
everything is moving as fast as possible
this is more for the factory than for
you they'll send you back around a
thousand units and they're you should be
continuing to use the console to run and
test metrics on these devices and
finally for mass production you should
be using the developer console to send
any zero updates if needed and gather
more metrics on these devices so as you
can see here as you move through the
process they should be sending devices
back to you the whole time and you
should be testing those devices giving
feedback extensively through QA and one
other note from a design perspective as
you move forward through this framework
your solutions might need to get more
creative more MacGyver II and lean more
towards software solutions because it
might be too expensive or too late to go
backwards and start over again if you're
working with a product team so some of
the tools that you can use to make this
all go a lot smoother is the developer
console so we've included something new
called the app library this allows you
to add apps to you can this allows you
to add apps to the app library and use
them on multiple projects so if you have
multiple lanterns for example you can
write one apk upload it to the App
library and then you can use it
throughout each of your different
products
when you're ready to test over-the-air
updates you can create releases and
channels and so sorry when you're ready
to build you can actually go through and
use the you can use the build settings
and then you can create a build
individually and run through each of the
steps to set all of the firmware and
software for your device and then you
create a build very seamlessly and when
you're ready to test over-the-air
updates you can create releases and
channels you can push those releases to
channels so you can test your software
in different groups for detailed testing
so for example here I'm creating custom
channel I'm creating an update and I'm
going to push these updates to my
devices or my fleets of devices
wirelessly and finally after you release
you can gather metrics to help you
gather quantitative data on your
products to help you make better
decisions about what you need to do next
so for example in Lantern version 0.1
you have maybe a set set of features
that you want to use and then you want
to move on in a quick draw you can do so
fairly easily by using the build tool
and then you can check in metrics to see
if it's doing better and once your
device is in the market the feedback
doesn't stop there so you should be
gathering feedback doing user testing
and checking everything as your device
is in the market through any updates
that you've created continue doing user
testing continued doing gorilla testing
anything that's in that research column
you should be continuing to do to help
you create updates for your products and
also help you define the next iteration
cycles through your thing and that's the
process so we've taken you through
ideation prototyping with Android things
kits making final Hardware selections
creating builds and hardware bring up
the factory process all the way to the
end product with maintenance and updates
running through design iterations each
step of the way thanks Kristen
and so we've talked about today how
design is people in context with goals
and it's a process we can plan prototype
feedback and iterate on that process in
order to help those people in those
contexts achieve those goals and now
it's easier than ever to participate in
the creation of physical products then
it has been ever good for Android things
offers tools to help accelerate the
prototyping process that you can use
today to kick-start your ideas
processing enables the fast experience
experimentation of rich graphics and
when combined with hardware enables you
to make really powerful experiences all
of these techniques really enable you to
make better connected products for
everyone using Android things you can
get started today at experiments dot
with google.com slash Lantern you can
check out some of the samples projects
and more at Android things with
google.com if you picked up a kid today
there's lots of sample code over there
for you to try out if you haven't gotten
a kit you can get one over at the IOT
dome a big thank you to the Nord group
Ben Joe and Mike for helping out with
this project ding on the Android things
UX team for managing all of the
intercontinental prototyping that was
required for this and Chloe on the
Android things ml team for making all of
the ml magic come to life please check
it out we'd love to see you over there
thank you guys for coming and if you
have feedback we do want to hear from
you and you can do so right here
[Music]